bonjour eric zemmour l'assemblée
nationale discute actuellement le projet
de loi visant à conforter les principes
de la république
c'est un bon programme et pourtant selon
vous le débat est déjà clos avant
d'avoir été ouvert pour quoi vous savez
la sémantique c'est important en
politique
et vous avez vu qu'après le discours
présidentiel des mureaux qui parlait de
séparatisme islamique on est rentré sous
terre et on a supprimé et les mots
séparatisme islamique pur
mais non c'est anodin kim qui ne menace
qui ne menace ni ne vexer personne
deuxième deuxième censure on a vu quand
la députée oran berger en marche
pourtant a voulu parler du voile des
fillettes même pas des femmes dans la
rue lcl a été rabroué par son président
de groupe castaner et le premier
ministre lui même
vous voyez c'était circulez ya rien à
voir pas de pas de voix bien
l'inspiration de ce texte qui si vous
voulez essaye de ne de ne vexer personne
devriez donner insulté personne et
surtout de ne pas montrer l'adversaire
et et de ne pas dire qu'il ya un
problème avec l'islam qu'il y a un
problème avec l'islam tout simplement
parce que l'islam est à la fois une
religion une fois et un projet juridico
politique qui a une emprise sur le
social et sur la société qui est qui est
à l'origine de cette contre société que
maintenant les autorités dénoncent le
après avoir nier cela c'est à dire
qu'une construit aussi été qui repose à
la fois sur la loi religieuse islamique
et les moeurs islamique pour vous le
problème c'est l'assimilation c'est pas
la laïcité
ah oui le problème c'est pas la laïcité
c'est l'assimilation
on veut continuer à croire que c'est une
question d'acide de laïcité alors que
c'est pas la laïcité le problème le
problème c'est l'assimilation c'est est
ce que des gens venus d'ailleurs
s'assimile au mode de vie français au
l'esprit français à l'histoire de france
voyez est ce que ce qu'ont fait les
vagues d'immigration précédente
leleu la question de l'islam se
surajoute à cette question tout
simplement pour deux raisons parce que
je vous ai dit l'islam et à projets
juridico politique et donc sociale et
deuxièmement que l'islam lui même est
une machine d'assimilation
extraordinaire qui est assimilé depuis
mille ans des peuples très divers voyez
donc il y à une lutte une lutte entre
deux modèle assimilationniste et notre
modèle à simulation qui était très fort
et est très fort les nos élites y ont
renoncé
on a bien vu le président mâcon lui-même
dit l'assimilation elle est encore dans
le code civil mais c'est parce que nous
voulons nous voulons l'intégration or
l'intégration
ce n'est pas la simulation de
l'intégration c'est le modèle
multiculturaliste même si emmanuel
macron s'en défend l'assimilation c'est
devenir le même l'intégration c'est
respecter la loi du pays où l'on vit
mais avec ses moeurs avec son sa
civilisation et ça forcément ça crée les
deux civilisations sur le même sol sacré
les contres société sacré le séparatiste
on ne veut pas voir
pour être concret est ce que selon vous
pour respecter l'identité française
il faut bannir toute exposition publique
des croix des kippas ou décroissant
islamique
la laïcité c'est la liberté religieuse
et c'est le devoir de discrétion
religieuse dans l'espace public ça c'est
pour toutes les religions ça il n'y a
pas de sujet il faut que la discrétion
religieux pour ne pas empiéter support
le pas pour ne pas empiéter sur les
autres voiliers pour respecter les
autres et pour que le débat politique se
fasse dans la rationalité et non pas
dans l'irrationnel religion ça c'est la
base de la laïcité qu'on l'a
complètement oublié pour la limiter à
une loi de liberté lui merci eric
zemmour